coming up from a sky source within
afghanistan it says that the taliban has
issued a statement banning all kinds of
protests and demonstrations in kabul
and other provinces the statement that
has come from the taliban apparently
says that without prior permissions from
the justice and interior ministry no one
is allowed to get onto the street to
protest now this course comes in night
of a number of protests we've seen over
the last few days and perhaps most
notably a protest yesterday with a lot
of women out on the streets protesting
against the loss of of their human
rights but there are also protests with
men and women protesting about the
taliban um the taliban are saying that
if they do carry out such a protest
again and anything happens to them it
would be their own responsibility
um and our source in afghanistan says
that basically they are creating such
tough conditions that it will be very
difficult for anyone to obtain
permission to protest so basically the
taliban saying no
to all protests of course a lot of eyes
on the taliban they have told
us and if they tell sky new specifically
that they were very different
organization to the one that they were
20 years ago that it was going to be
very different
afghanistan with the taliban in control
all eyes now watching to see what
actually happens in reality and this
here a sign that they are certainly
rowing back on some of those commitments